>> Tucker: STRANGE CIRCUMSTANCES
CONTINUE TO SWIRL AROUND THE LAS
VEGAS SHOOTING 4 MONTHS AGO.
REFUSEED TO RELEASE THE
AUTOPSIES OF 58 SHOOTING VICTIMS
IN RESPONSE TO A COURT ORDER,
BUT REFUSEED TO RELEASE THE
AUTOPSY OF SHOOTER STEPHEN
PADDOCK.
HE CLAIMS THE AUTOPSY IS STILL
BEING FINALIZED AFTER ALL OF
THIS TIME.
DOCTOR, THIS SEEMS LIKE A WEIRD
ECPLANITION.
YOU HAVE PERSPECTIVE.
>> CORONERS AND MEDICAL
EXAMINERS HAVE TO OBEY JUDICIAL
ORDER, PERIOD.
IT MAY BE A SITUATION WHERE THE
AUTOPSY FINDINGS MAY BE
IMPORTANT IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION THAT THE DISTRICT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH THEIR
SITUATION.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SAYING THIS
ANYTHING WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
WHAT COULD BE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE AUTOPSY RESULTS AND
THE CONTINUING INVESTIGATION?
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN THE BODY HAS
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE ALL OF
THE OTHER AUTOPSY HAVE BEEN
RELEASED AS A RESULT OF THE
JUDICIAL ORDER, THE COURT ARE
THE.
WHY THIS ONE WOULD NOT BE.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD WE LEARN
OF INTEREST FROM AN AUTOPSY?
>> WELL, IT'S INTERESTING WHEN
YOU HAVE 58 PEOPLE DIE, WHO SEEM
TO HAVE BEEN SHOT.
WHY DO AUTOPSIES AT ALL?
ONE OF THE REASONS IS TO RECOVER
ALL OF THE BULLETS THAT WERE
FIRED.
TO FIND IF THERE IS A BULLET
SHOOTER.
TO SEE IF THERE WAS A SECOND
SHOOTER POSSIBLY WOULD BE ONE OF
THE REASONS.
THE BULLET WE LEAVE BEHIND IS
THE BULLET THAT COMES FROM A
DIFFERENT GUN.
THAT'S ONE REASON FOR THE
AUTOPSY.
THE OTHERS, IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS NOT EVERYBODY IS
AUTOPSIED IF THE SHOOTING
OBVIOUSLY CAUSES THE DEATH.
IN THIS SITUATION ALL BODIES
SHOULD BE AUTOPSIED AND ALL OF
THE INJURIES IDENTIFIED AND THE
ISSUES WILL COME UP OF  PAIN AND
SUFFERING.
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE DIED FROM THE
STAMPEDE GETTING OUT RATHER THAN
OF A BULLET.
WE WERE TOLD BY AUTHORITIES HE
WAS THE ONLY ONE IN THE HOTEL
ROOM AND THE ONLY ONE FIRING A
WEAPON AND DIED OF A
QUESTION]S.
THEY ARE HIDING THE AUTOPSY,
WHAT WOULD BE THEIR MOTIVE?
>> IF THERE WERE SOME ISSUES AND
THEY WERE DOING SOME STUDIES ON
THE BRAIN OF THE DECEDENT.
ALL OF THE INFORMATION COMING
OUT ABOUT CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
WAS THERE A BRAIN ISSUE THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN CONTRIBUTEED TO HIS
BIZARRE BEHAVIOR?
THEY MAY STILL BE LOOKING FOR
CERTAIN SPECIAL STAINS AND
CHEMIAL ANALYSIS OF THE BRAIN.
THAT COULD BE THE REASON IT'S
NOT COMPLETED.
USUAL THE REASON THE AUTOPSY IS
NOT IMMEDIATELY RELEASED TO THE
NEXT OF KIN IT TO DO THE
ANALYSIS TO FIND IF THIS WAS ANY
SINCE OCTOBER 1st, ANY
TOXICOLOGY EXAMINATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE.
IT'S UNLIKELY THERE IS A GOOD
REASON NOT TO RELEASE THE
PADDOCK TO THE NEXT OF KIN.
NOT NECESSARILY TO THE --
>> Tucker: I GET IT.